trevor rogers has been a stud for this
marlin starting rotation throughout the
year
and he makes his first start since july
20th about a week and a half on the il
with some lower back
muscle spasms he starts the night out
with a strikeout torres is down on
strikes
one strikeout for trevor rogers here to
kick things off this evening
and another strikeout here back-to-back
case for trevor rogers
first pitch swinging aaron judge a fly
ball out to right field
brian de la cruz makes the catch
vermont this will be his 18th start 21st
game four and five 4.45
he is facing his original organization
for the first time in his career he
was with the marlins until he was traded
to the yankees in 2014.
line drive and right there is o'dorin's
short right field
took a base hit away from chisholm one
away
odor gets another try
and he gets rojas the 3-2 is hitting the
air to right field
fairly deep backwards gallow to make the
catch and that will take care of the
first day
but here's anthony rizzo to lead it off
for the angst
up and in and that gets rizzo and he
will take first base
it actually got the top of the hands
giancarlo with 252.
and that one is lined into the gap and
that is going to be
let's see if it's a home run or one off
the wall
and stopping at third is rizzo instead
gets himself a double
now they're saying it's a home run the
second base empire saying it's a home
run
so stan said well should i run now
they're all going to confirm
and they're sending them back to second
base good call
was off the wall just missed a home run
second and third nobody out
in field back and it's a line drive
single
to right field scoring easily as rizzo
stanton will stop at third it's an
rbi single 4-0 door he continues to rake
it's one-nothing eggs and that'll bring
up gary sanchez
two one skyed the other way and deep
is it going to be a fair ball yes it is
it bounces
over the wall so one run will score and
odor will go to third it's two
nothing yankees it's a ribby double for
sanchez
and the yankees take a two nothing lead
the tying runs are on first and second
one out two nothing yanks bottom of the
second
swing it missed snap throw to first not
in time
looked like riggs was loading up to
punch him out but then
said safe yeah they're gonna take a look
at it but this was a play because rizzo
came around
snuck around and made a great sweet tag
and did he get it
i think he got him out great throw by
sanchez and got de la cruz for the
second half really helped his pitcher
out
swinging and a miss and hermond works
around the two walks with a little help
from his friend now we go to the bottom
of the third
and strike three to rogers two away
this one had a ball in the dirt almost
hit him and a one two three inning
for domingo hermann two-way here's jory
alfaro walked his first time up
and this one out toward left center
field that is gonna
get down it's off the wall rojas will
score alfaro on his way to second
alfaro on his way to third
alfaro is gonna stay put and he got back
just in time and for two and his bounce
off that sidewall for tyler wade
well we're looking for a big swing we're
gonna get one the big guy
leans on a curveball 80 miles an hour
out over the plate
airmont left this one up alfaro ready
for
he rockets it into the gap and watch him
go
i'll tell you we had a pretty fun
perspective for the tying run 90 feet
away but 02 on
de la cruz
[Applause]
they pretty much caught him clean right
off the the face mask and thankfully he
is standing
that is a 90 2 3 4 mile an hour fastball
goodness anthony bender comes in with
the bases loaded
and geo or shell a pinch hitting for
domingo herman
and that one gets past alfaro here comes
rizzo
and he will score three two yankees we
talked about el faro and last night
about the past
balls and this might be wild pitch or
passport we'll see but he does lead the
major leagues this will be his 12th
payoff pitch from bender swinging a miss
for strike three
alfaro hung on
[Applause]
yankees do get one to retake the lead
stephen oaker
will take over this will be his 12th
game and he's going to
face a lefty first off in anthony rizzo
deep to right field if it's fair it's
gone it is
gone another rizzo blast
his second home run is a yankee this one
another
tape measure job and the yankees lead
four to two anthony rizzo putting on a
little show
in his debut here in miami with the
yankees and
another bomb these balls are just not in
the first row
what a debut for anthony rizzo the first
couple games
and clay holmes will take over for lucas
litke we saw holmes in tampa in his
debut
and he threw the ball really well he's
got a good sinking fastball
uses it a lot that one is
chopped off the plate waiting for it
come down as odor fires to first gets
alfaro one away
here's the 1-02 d-la cruz he hits a
brown ball to shore
taurus fields throws through he's two
for two
two ground balls and if holmes is
throwing the ball the way he wants it's
exactly what you're going to see
infielders would be ready
knowing they're going to get some ground
balls and boy rizzo he just looks so
comfortable three ground balls
for holmes and three outs in a row
as the marlins go down and we'll go to
the eighth inning well the new pitcher
for the yankees is jonathan lewis again
so here's lewin diaz he comes up as the
time run
good way to get a ground ball like that
just like that there's one not in time
as rizzo couldn't come up with the scoop
that was one of those times paul we
always talk about it that's where the
the the shift plays against you there
was nobody at second to get the throw
now you can see he tagged him with the
glove and the ball was in the hand
so the morelands are saying anderson is
at third and they are still pleading
their case that
anderson should be at third not at
second so it will
be that they keep him at second the
one-two
grinded to third over the second they
get the force and the yankees win
four to two no doubt about it the
yankees go away again happy not a
blowout another kind of a nail biter for
us michael but you know what
anthony rizzo has been a big part of
this two-game win streak in miami